Ladies and gentlemen, I'm here to respond to Stephanie Georgie,
who said that my video confessions of a copywriter was unfair to the industry
and falsely painted them in a bad light. Hey,
it's just a few bad apples in direct response.
Most of them are doing it ethically.
So I'm making this response in return called delusions of a copywriter. Now,
Stephanie has a special reason for wanting to defend his profession. Number one,
he sold $700 million worth of product. So, okay. It's what he does. That's fine.
Um,
but also he's engaged in some of the terrible practices that I describe in my
video, but I wanted to say,
because I think I'll probably offend a few people in this video right up top.
I think most direct response copywriting that is going on right now in
this industry is ethically indefensible.
And I also want it to throw down the gauntlet. Look,
if you disagree with that statement, come on the show.
I'm happy to give you a platform. If you think any of this that's in Stephan,
Georgie's little post here is defensible.
Please come on the show because I think it'd be a great conversation to have,
because so far, you know,
you just post in this Facebook group where everyone agrees with you.
What are we going to do right now?
Notice I did not say that all copywriting is ethically indefensible or all
direct response. Copywriting is ethically indefensible.
Cause I don't think it is. I think there are ethical copywriters,
definitely out there, which makes the first thing.
This guy says that the main premise of my book is direct response, copywriting,
a scammy and responsible for ripping people off false.
And maybe that's because he only watched the first 20 minutes or so,
but, uh, yeah, that's wrong.
The main premise is actually that the majority of directors
copywriting is scammy and responsible for ripping people off.
There's ethical copywriting. Obviously there's ethical copywriting,
obviously a small difference,
but an important distinction because I'm not painting. He,
his whole point is that I paint the whole industry with one brush. No,
I just happened to be talking about the most predatory side of the industry,
but I'm not painting the whole industry with one brush, but anyways,
let's talk about what he says, okay, I'm going to have to summarize it.
But if you want to read the whole post, I will leave it in the description.
So basically he says, look, direct response, copywriting,
normal advertising Coca-Cola Hey, uh,
Gora Coca-Cola Swiffer new market health.
What's really the difference right now.
He does concede that some of the claims in copywriting are a little ridiculous,
but he says, look, when it comes to the product, things like this,
it's about the same, right? Some things work,
some things kind of work and some things just are pixie dust. He calls it right.
And he concludes it with this example, look, he says, Swiffer sweeper.
They kind of lie to you in their ad.
They make it look so easy to pick up dust and spills.
And does it really work that well? So he says, look,
it goes into the mixed results back,
but does that mean Swiffer is preying on the weak or that they're a scammy
company that should be banned from advertising on TV.
Seems hard to make that leap in my mind.
So he equates what he does to the Swiffer sweeper.
Now let's dig into what he does because notice he didn't bring up
any of the products, indirect response.
And I think that was smart of him because if he had,
it would have started to look pretty ridiculous because let's talk about one of
the products Stephan, Georgie has sold.
And I apologize for not using a more recent one,
but honestly it's hard to find out what these people have written about because
their names aren't on anything.
You kind of have to hunt down what they are actually attached to.
So he definitely wrote this. This is something called memory healer. Okay.
Now ask yourself,
do you think this is about the same level of predatory as Swiffer sweeper,
the evil broom company. Do you think this is slightly more predatory?
Do you think this is definitely more predatory? What do you think?
Maybe Swiffer sweepers more predatory. Okay.
Hi,
my name is Alexander Lynch and the incredible story you're about to hear is
100% true.
Actually first let's start with some irony.
The story is a hundred percent false.
About three and a half years ago.
My father pointed a shotgun to my face and pulled the trigger.
He didn't do it because he was a psycho or because there was some sort of a
family feud. It happened because when I unintentionally startled him,
his early stage two Alzheimer's, which at that time hadn't been diagnosed,
caused him to become panicked and confused, running to the closet.
He pulled out his 12 gauge and fired it right at my head.
He simply believed he was protecting his home and didn't realize that he almost
murdered his only son.
It was most disturbing and horrifying experiences for both of us.
Something that still gives me nightmares to this day.
And it's also what sent me on a complete.
By the way, I know that this seems like ridiculous,
like who would fall for this, but who is this product targeted towards?
It's about Alzheimer's right. It's targeted towards seniors.
So they're actually trying to scare seniors or maybe the seniors,
a son or daughter. So look,
so what they're taking advantage of seniors,
isn't that the same as selling a Swift.
Slightly unexpected two year long journey through the dark underbelly of the
multi-billion dollar corporate medicine universe,
a journey that opened my eyes to the sick predatory and ultimately
deadly practices of the pharmaceutical conglomerates.
And that would eventually lead to the discovery of a completely natural
100% effective way that could reverse even the most severe cases
of Alzheimer's dementia.
Oops. Hey, this is not the Swiffer sweeper.
You're trying to scare seniors into selling them a a hundred
percent effective way that could reverse the most severe cases of Alzheimer's
and dementia, which by the way, incurable diseases.
No matter whether the one suffering was in the very.
Late, I don't even want to put you guys through this.
They're targeting people who are in their last stage of
life and trying to milk them for all the money they're worth.
Now,
that is what I would call something that is preying on the weak or a
scammy company that should be banned. That is what I'm talking about.
And with that, I want to talk about what makes a predatory advertiser,
because Devin doesn't seem to understand what makes a company predatory.
It's pretty simple.
What makes all the difference in the world is pushing your product onto
desperate people who have no choice,
but to buy it and overcharging them for it while you're at it.
So this happens primarily in two industries, two industries, by the way,
which direct response, copywriters, love health and wealth.
Okay. Now why do these attract desperate people? Well,
because let's take the example of a health. Let's take the extreme case.
Say you're offering a cancer drug, right? Someone's been told by their doctors,
Hey, you're you're honestly, we have nothing left for you.
That's usually when people go to these direct response copywriters,
they're looking for a salvation, right? They're looking for a miracle pill.
These are desperate people that will pay any price.
And you appeal to them with products. Like the one we just saw,
like this memory healer right here,
you take their money and they have no recourse, but to buy it right,
because you have to try it. You're going to try it either way.
Even though it might look scummy,
you might not trust the person you're going to buy it.
The same is true with wealth products.
If you tell me I'm going to get rich and I work at McDonald's a nine to five job
making minimum wage, right? I'm going to buy your product, which in of itself,
isn't the end of the world. But as you and I both know,
most of these products simply do not work. Or if they do work,
they work for 1%, maybe half a percent of people,
not the a hundred percent success rate that is usually promised in the copy.
That's what makes it predatory because you're preying on the lowest level,
the lowest denominator of society to try to take their money.
And that's who a lot of these people are targeting.
It's not people who are well to do engineers, right?
Who have their life together. It is desperate people,
either a desperate mom who needs to lose weight and you're selling them. Some,
some solution, you know, is not going to work.
Or there's some old person you're selling them. Health cures that you know,
is not going to work or they're young and you're selling them some get rich.
Biz-op right. These are the classics of direct response.
It's the foundation on which a lot of this industry is built.
Now with that said with, uh, the,
this obvious point debunked here,
I want to go on because one of his biggest things that I take issue with is that
look, he says to bait the whole industry as seedy and crappy. First of all,
I didn't paint the whole industry. I just painted most of the industry, uh,
as crappy because of some bad actors doesn't seem fair.
Because when you look at the biggest players,
most of whom I've written for what you find is they don't use sensational
stories.
They're incessantly focused on making sure their claims are legit and they
really genuinely care about their products. Uh,
are you nuts?
This is exactly the point I'd make. But in reverse, look,
I actually agree with Stephen that if you want to evaluate an industry,
you don't look at the worst. You look at the best of the industry, right?
The top of the industry.
So when you look at the top of the advertising industry, who might you find,
you might find, I don't know, Apple, they're selling a real product, right?
You might find Amazons and you might find the Verizon wireless is you might find
Coca Cola. These people look,
you can argue that Cola is not going to bring you happiness.
So that's like a little deceptive,
but they're not appealing to people who are on their last leg. Okay.
Now let's move away from that. And talk about direct response.
If you look at the best in the direct response game, who do you talk about?
Well, the obvious cases, a Gora right?
They're the biggest company in direct response.
And actually all Stephan Georgie should know because one of the companies they
talk about training is a glorified financial.
So this must be then one of the companies that, uh, Stephan really stands by,
they don't use sensational stories.
They're insistently focused on making sure their claims are legit.
They really genuinely care about their products. Oh, do they? Hey,
why don't we talk about that?
This is something called a deep dive into the heart and mind of the financial
publication buyer.
This is done by the in-house copywriter at a Gore financial.
And he's about to talk to salesmen who talked to their customers.
And we're about to find out what they really believe.
They say about their own customers. They really are looking for the magic pill.
That would be my distillation of about 10 years.
They're talking about their customers.
They're looking for the financial magic pill.
Now let me go out on a limb here and say that they're attracting customers who
are looking for a magic pill because they're selling magic pills.
And you might say, well, that's just my opinion,
but consider how weird it would be.
If a car salesman said that people were coming,
looking for anything other than cars,
you attract people based on what you're selling.
So it stands to reason that if the distillation of 10 years of selling is that
people come to your company looking for a magic pills. Well,
what do you think you're selling?
And it's not me saying that that's their own copywriter and salesman who admit
that they say about their customers.
It's a lot of people who are panicked back against the wall,
trying to make up for lost time, sound like desperation to you.
These people at the top of the direct response industry, Agoro financial,
who step in says, Oh yeah, right. What did he say? Oh,
they don't use sensational stories here. They are in their own words.
Talking about using sensational stories. Yeah. Well the retire a millionaire.
I don't know what it was. 30 day retirement blue. Yeah. That one.
That was hell on the phone. People like, here's a good example of the power.
Like you get it, the power of copy. Right. But when that promo first launched,
I remember specifically, and this was God, probably six years ago.
I talked to people out of retiring that day. Like two people were like,
I'm going to go tell my boss off I'm out of here. I said,
maybe you're going to want to give it the 30 days before you, well,
let's talk about this.
Protect your money and pile up as much as 794 profits during China's
deliberate economic attack. OneAmerica Hey,
does that sound like a curiosity inducing story or a sensational story?
Right. Secondly,
he says they are incessantly focused on making sure their claims are legit.
This is also simply false. And again,
I'm not taking the low hanging fruit of Stephan Georgie's, you know,
memory Marie healer from several years ago, I could do that all day,
but let me take the top players in your industry.
People new market health who got sued by the federal trade commission for
lying about diabetes. And again, if anyone wants to defend this and say that no,
the big players industry are super honest. No,
our industry isn't especially bad.
Please come on and imagine for a second that some mainstream advertisers did
this. They never would. This is uniquely a direct response copywriting problem.
And the sooner people in the industry address it.
The sooner you guys can move on to better practices,
but I'll get into why I don't think that's going to happen in a second.
Look at what they say. Do you suffer from type two diabetes? Well,
maybe your doctor has told you to keep an eye on your blood sugar.
This guy says there's a simple at-home treatment for type two diabetes.
That has nothing to do with diet or exercise involves no drugs,
reverse every symptom of diabetes in 28 days without changing your diet
without spending a minute in the gym or taking a single drug. And no,
I'm not even kidding. This is from one of the top players in your industry,
your TV, your cell phone,
even the computer screen you're watching on can slowly silently cause type two
diabetes. And then they show a diabetes rate and then electronic device usage,
this usage like that must be causation, right?
That couldn't just be correlation abandoned your workouts,
abandoned your insulin, just get IRR blockers. Totally insane.
Now I'm going to argue that a lot of what makes Stephan wrong here is that
he conflates the difference between illegal and unethical
right there. Those are two very different things.
There are a lot of things that are legal to do that.
Many of us would consider unethical. Now, unfortunately, some of this industry,
not all of it, certainly not all of it,
but some of this industry thinks that if you ever try to start pushing back and
saying, Hey, maybe this is unethical.
Even if it's legal to do all of a sudden, Oh, you must Kate making money.
You must Kate making money. That's what this guy says, Tim.
I find that a lot of people who watch my channel is there to reconfirm their
beliefs on making money. That everyone is a scam. Everyone is greedy.
Everyone is bad. No, just you Tim.
It's almost like they're trying to convince themselves that making a lot of
money is evil again. No,
but some ways of making money as evil selling the memory healer
is evil. It's unethical. Even if Stephan,
Georgie never technically got prosecuted for it.
Even if it was never considered illegal, it is deeply unethical.
And I don't know why that's a conversation. No one's willing to have,
but because he conflates those two things, uh, he, he, when he says this,
they're incessantly focused on making sure their claims are legit.
It's what he's actually saying is they're incessantly focused on making sure
their claims are legal. Not that they don't want vs claims.
They want as many BS claims as they can possibly fit
while staying legal. And once again, I'm going to show you proof of this.
This is Jenny Thompson, CEO of new market health,
which is a branch of a Gora here's her idea of legality.
Notice the equation for what should be said is anything short of completely
illegal?
Making sure again, that our claims are kind of right up to the line,
but not something that can get shut down, making sure again,
that our claims are kind of right up to the line.
Um, and I could really do this all day.
I could go after sales letter after sales letter with you,
but I think you get the point. The point is,
is this is a ridiculous attempt to try to justify
the really terrible things that are going on in this industry. And again,
it's not the whole industry, but it is a lot of the big players he's lying.
When he says that the big players are somehow the ethical ones.
How do you figure that buddy?
Here's Joseph Schrieffer one of the top guys at a Gora financial, uh,
who we talked about earlier,
who Stephen Mustang is a pinnacle of ethics since they're a big player.
And he says the big players are all ethical. Here's him saying?
We're simply trying to find out what the new rules will be.
This is right after a Facebook ad crackdown, how that impacts our copy.
And if we can still acquire customers with the water down claims,
if we can't say you're going to make all this money to get promised you the
moon, how who's going to buy our products.
You'd never see this with a Coca-Cola ad.
You'd never see this in an Apple ad. Hey, can we still acquire customers?
Now? You'd never say that.
Cause they're not saying they're going to make you 112% of your wealth.
They're not appealing to desperate people in desperate situations.
So I wanted to point that out,
that difference that he fails to really highlight. He says, Oh,
maybe we do a little bit more claims. So basically we're just,
it's just a different medium, right? Hey, some of our work,
some of them don't know your, your industry is unique.
It's uniquely predatory because it preys on people in desperate situations.
It uses ridiculous claims,
way more over the top than any ad you'd ever see on TV.
This is not Swiffer vs the memory healer.
This is not Swiffer versus the diabetes cure of a Gore.
They're not even in the same league and combine that with the fact that I've
effectively debunked the idea that just because they're a big player, Oh,
look at the big players there. They're ethical, right? They're the ethical ones.
Sure. At the bottom, you may find problems. But look at the people at the top,
Hey, we've looked at the people at the top, go look at a Gore,
go look at their advertising.
They're the exact example I'd use as the textbook for why, uh,
Mike Case with Jim was completely dead on. So anyways,
let me know what you think. Let me know Stephan.
If you want to come on the show and uh, have this little chat,
I hope you're as willing to defend your industry live as you were in this piece.
And um, yeah. See you guys next.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].